you fool
gambling made it profitable to have
fights all the time because people loved
gamble so they'd have all these people
fighting in ties they even altered their
style to accommodate the gambling like
the first round they would go real slow
because they wanted everybody to place
their bets so P they would just take it
slow and everybody knew the fight didn't
really begin to the 2nd or the 3rd round
so it wasn't like American fighting
where you would have like a Mike Tyson
who'd be cherished for knocking people
out very quickly like what there would
be over/under bets is this guy is Tony
Tubbs gonna last the first 3 run 3
minutes of the fight you know is Michael
Spinks gonna last the first 30 like
world-class fighters dude imagine get
hit by Mike Tyson when he was 20 years
old no matter how horrible that would be
he was at the fights as fast weekend I
said I know Mike that's so weird
it's amazing he's still a tank too dude
terrifying looking person there's a
video of him hitting the bags like 51
years old or something like that
hitting the heavy bag and you're like
okay he could still [ __ ] you up 100%
like in terms of like retired
heavyweight champions there was a trend
that existed you know where the someone
would retire and then they would you
know they wouldn't they wouldn't keep
their form they would get heavy and that
happened with Mike he got like very
heavy look at this 49 year old 49 so
this is like two years ago yeah dude
[ __ ] all this give me some volume
[Music]
dude forty nine-year-old Mike Tyson will
put you to sleep 100% and when you're
around him you realize you like just
who's that oh that's Oh make see I blame
his trainers right there if I was the
guy holding the camera I'd be like stop
it okay first of all we got to
straighten this whole thing out before
you start hitting hard you gonna get a
move look at all this this might be just
a personal trainer not a boxing person
but I'm looking in the background and I
feel like I see boxing and stuff on the
wall play that play that video young
Mike Tyson with custom motto oh my god
I want to change the way you feel about
physics custom otto was old and dying he
was a really old guy but he had just
this deep knowledge of psychology and
boxing and he trained this unbelievably
fast and powerful talented kid who had
massive hunger for success that the
whole story of Mike Tyson a lot is
wrapped up in the story of custom otto
who had been around forever and this is
his last and greatest pupil and Mike
knew it Mike knew it what was happening
and by the time he won the heavyweight
championship custom mono had already
died but he dedicated it all to him
there was nobody like him you know
people like they say oh you know buddy
never fought Ollie and he never fought
these guys that you know his era people
weren't as good maybe maybe but
everybody in his Airy [ __ ] up all of
them up until spanks excuse me until my
sister Hendrix no well buster yeah
Buster was the first one to beat him but
I'm an Holyfield yeah that's how [ __ ]
up I am i said hendrix i was trying to
remember what the fight was when
Holyfield beat tyson those two fights in
a row like that was that was big and
when tyson bit his ear like that was big
like that was like when you realize like
he's just not he's not the same guy he
was we both lived in Columbus when
Buster Douglas knocked him out that was
a crazy like
became the big big [ __ ] hero no one
knew who he was really I feel I was
young but then he's supposed to have
take over the east side of the city he
was gonna change everything have a big
giant boxing gym it never happened you
know the story of Buster Douglas it's an
amazing story his mom died his mom died
when he was in training for the fight oh
really
and all of his life he had kind of been
really talented as a boxer but hadn't
really completely dedicated himself to
it so when his mom died he went
completely insane in the gym in
preparation for Tyson and then when came
out there he it was like two people that
had the exact opposite things happened
to them for Tyson he had just been
smashing everybody for so long he was so
good and so scary he would win fights
before they even even start it would
just be a matter of whether or not you
were gonna make it out of the first
round sometimes he was just smashing
people but for Buster Douglas is like he
had some good fights and some bad fights
and it just wasn't he wasn't completely
consistent but he was talented but then
when his mom died it was right when the
time when Tyson was you know just
overconfident he was a 46 to 1-under
daughter I think is that what it was I
think just marking it as Tyson his back
fight
oh wow I didn't know that yeah Tyson is
back I don't remember that what um what
were the odds because I think it was one
of the craziest odds of someone who want
to fight for you two to one it says yeah
42 to one is a lot that means you have
to be a total sucker to bet on Buster
Douglas but I'll take your money stupid
yeah yeah I'll give you $4,200 if you
give me one hundred you know it's like
they're so confident that Tyson's gonna
beat them they're willing to bet 42
times whatever you're gonna put up that
to me as always I think bets I'm not
telling you what to do but I think bets
should be like I think actually I check
it back I think should be able to
whatever you want but I think the real
bet should be who do you want who he
thinks gonna win let's make it real
clear who's gonna win if you say well we
Michael Spinks making out of the first
round like all right now we're getting
weird this is some [ __ ] you might be
able to affect maybe you might be able
to talk to Michael Mike there's a lot of
money in this fight there's even more if
we can get to the second round
no I'm saying bro the last bet I hit
like that was Amanda Nunez yeah okay oh
and second round Mike specifically
picked that that's very important to
protect against that kind of influence
because that shit's real that should
happen throughout sports if someone
comes up to you and goes look there's a
lot of money if this fight goes into the
third round it's all we gonna do okay
here's the odds 72 to 172 to 1 this
fight goes to the third round no that
means you let the fight go to the third
round won't make a lot more yeah